Trascrizione: Silvia Lancia
Revisore: Chiara Rossini
(Applausi)
Ciao a tutti,
sono Lorenzo Ceccotti.
Sono un disegnatore e mi occupo
di un sacco di cose differenti
che hanno a che fare con il disegno:
l'illustrazione, il graphic design,
l'industrial design...
Però ce n'è una in particolare
che mi è rimasta sempre a cuore
e che è balzata subito
alla mia attenzione,
prima in maniera un po' incosciente, poi
in maniera veramente molto consapevole,
ed è il fumetto.
Il fumetto ha delle
caratteristiche uniche,
poi ho scoperto che ha delle proprietà
che sono veramente incredibili,
motivo per cui non l'ho più abbandonato.
In particolar modo, il fatto di poter
raccontare qualunque storia visiva
vi passi per la testa,
con il budget di carta e penna.
È formidabile, molto meglio del cinema
da questo punto di vista,
che invece ha bisogno di grossi budget,
è decisamente più ingombrante come medium.
Invece la cosa per cui
mi sono interessato al fumetto,
prima quasi in una maniera masochista,
(Risata)
è il fatto che metteva seriamente
in difficoltà la mia idea
di cosa era bello o brutto nel disegno,
e non c'è cosa che preferisco fare
di più che fare disegni.
Ho iniziato a fare disegni
perché ovviamente a casa avevo
una famiglia di persone
che mi hanno educato a disegnare,
quindi già da piccolo,
mio papà faceva l'archietto,
mia mamma la musicista
ma ha disegnato sempre benissimo,
ci sono sempre stati fumetti
e libri illustrati a casa.
Quindi ogni volta che
facevo un bel disegno
prendevo una bella pacca sulla spalla,
mi sentivo bravo, quindi ne facevo di più.
Grazie a Dio questo attaccamento
al parere altrui si è perso nel tempo,
però all'inizio è stata una cosa che
sicuramente mi ha spinto a disegnare.
Il fumetto, invece,
metteva in crisi questo lato.
Io avevo già iniziato a studiare
la prospettiva e l'anatomia
fin da molto piccolo,
perché vivevo le mie giornate
nello studio di architettura di mio papà.
E i fumetti, invece, si presentano così.
Vedete, c'è una grossa contraddizione
nell'immagine che state vedendo,
perché possono essere disegnati così:
molto curati, con molta attenzione,
con un altissimo livello di dettaglio,
molto vicini al reale.
oppure, possono essere così:
sono disegni che, forse,
un disegnatore come questo qui
potrebbe derubricare come fatti male?
Non lo so, sta di fatto che
si presenta in entrambi i modi.
Questa questione, in realtà,
è stata risolta
da neuroscienziati e semiologi
dal punto di vista scientifico.
Io oggi vi voglio portare nel mio
percorso mentale da disegnatore e artista,
per capire perché queste due strade
sono così interessanti,
ma in particolare la seconda
per un disegnatore,
e perché richiede un po' di cultura
per essere capita fino in fondo.
Io sono un disegnatore che lavora,
mi guadagno da vivere,
perché la gente dice che i miei disegni
sono graficamente belli.
Sono cresciuto con l'idea che il disegno
per essere bello dovesse essere curato,
fatto con molta attenzione,
con la tecnica, fin da piccolo.
I nodi sono venuti al pettine subito:
uscito dalla famiglia in cui tutti
ti vogliono bene, ti vezzeggiano,
e ti tengono in grande considerazione,
quando ho cominciato ad andare a scuola
si è creata la situazione per cui
spesso capitava, vi sarà successo,
che ci si faceva i disegni sui diari.
"Mi fai la caricatura?"
"Mi dicono che sei bravo a disegnare,
mi disegni questo personaggio?"
E io non ci riuscivo.
Perché ero molto strutturato,
dovevo prima fare la matita sotto,
poi ci dovevo pensare,
dovevo capire da dove veniva la luce.
Poi arrivava un mio compagno di classe,
che coglieva l'aspetto divertente
di una persona in cinque secondi,
con un'intuizione, qualcosa che
non avevo idea da dove venisse fuori.
Era una cosa che non solo
mi faceva un male micidiale,
mi faceva proprio paura, mi dicevo:
"Quindi forse sto sbagliando tutto".
E quel modo di disegnare faceva
contenti tutti, tutti erano felici,
tutti ridevano di questo disegno.
Questi disegni, fatti così.
Era il modo con cui tutti quanti
si divertivano a disegnare.
Raccontavano le loro storie,
mentre io stavo ancora a cercare
di capire cosa avrei dovuto fare.
Oppure c'era chi imparava a memoria
a disegnare un personaggio
dei cartoni animati,
e lo facevano benissimo,
ma non sapevano disegnare
minimamente, erano bambini piccoli.
Mentre io facevo già la prospettiva
a due punti di fuga, da architetto, no?
E non facevo ridere nessuno,
quindi era una situazione terribile.
Ovviamente, questa cosa all'inizio
non l'ho metabolizzata molto bene:
ero un bambino, quindi ero ignorante,
sostanzialmente stupido, insopportabile,
mi sentivo più bravo degli altri,
avevo tutti i difetti del mondo.
Questa cosa mi ha portato a darmi
una serie di risposte stupide,
prima di tutto quella di dire:
"Qual è allora il segreto per fare
un disegno veramente bello?"
Non ho cercato di capire perché
quei disegni funzionano o no,
la mia idea è stata quella di mettere
la testa sotto la sabbia
e di scavare ancora più giù.
Mi sono detto:
"Un disegno bello,
per non essere criticabile e colpire tutti
deve essere ancora più realistico.
Devo andare in una direzione in cui sembra
che ho un motore 3D al posto del cervello,
devo disegnare tutto quello
che mi passa per la testa
nella maniera più realistica possibile,
perché chi può contestare la realtà?"
Questa cosa ha riverberato
nella mia vita da disegnatore
a vari livelli.
Io oggi farò delle confessioni che
rimangono tra queste mura,
il regista di questi TED ha detto che
se voglio questo video verrà distrutto.
(Risata)
Possiamo dire che è venuto male.
Però vi confesso che da piccolo
andavo in una scuola di suore,
una scuola privata, e in una gita
ci hanno portato a vedere Assisi
e io ho visto Giotto per la prima volta.
Dicevano:
"Un grande maestro della storia dell'arte,
il miglior disegnatore, incredibile,
l'apice dell'arte sacra".
Vedevo questi disegni e dicevo:
"Ma questo non sa disegnare.
Cosa c'è di bello?
Nel senso, sono piatti,
a me piacciono di più i Masters,
sono disegnati meglio i Masters di Alcala.
Ci sono i muscoli, la prospettiva,
sono fichissimi".
Quindi vedevo
questa roba qui e dicevo: "Boh".
Da bambino di 8 anni,
non capivo com'era possibile,
perché io ero nato nel mondo
dell'immagine cinematografica
dove l'immagine era già sofisticatissima.
L'immagine fotografica, quindi il reale,
aveva sostituito proprio
il linguaggio del disegno di Giotto.
Io non lo potevo capire Giotto,
non potevo, mi piacevano di più i Masters.
Allora che cosa ho fatto?
Ho cominciato a studiarmi
tutti i pittori realistici,
partendo da Leonardo in poi.
Prima di Leonardo,
perché mi dovevo guardare indietro?
Prima era così,
invece andiamo avanti da qui.
Ho studiato Caravaggio,
la camera oscura,
una macchina fotografica su tela,
una cosa praticamente formidabile.
Chiaramente questo è il modo
più dozzinale per dirlo,
non è affatto così. (Risata)
Però, da bambino vedevo quest'immagine
e dicevo: " Sembra una foto!"
Ero ancora più cretino, sempre peggio.
Da lì, sono andato a studiare
tutti i fumettisti che disegnavano così,
che peraltro sono meravigliosi,
non li sto derubricando assolutamente,
però mi intrigava questo tipo di disegno:
Corben, Frazzetta, Bisley,
ancora Frazzetta, ancora Bisley,
Tanino Liberatore.
Perché erano dei disegnatori
che in qualche modo,
ragionavano come avrei voluto
ragionare io, no?
Disegnare come se fossero delle
macchine fotografiche sul reale,
quindi con l'idea di disegnare il reale,
cercando di mettere
l'impressione del reale nel disegno.
Era incontestabile, era proprio
un obiettivo misero il mio,
quello di essere approvato.
Questo non vuol dire che sia lo scopo
di un disegnatore come Liberatore,
che è agli antipodi umani
di quello che ho appena detto.
Però avevo trovato un conforto
in quel tipo di disegno.
Questo è Sid Milton,
un altro disegnatore formidabile,
Questa cosa si è estesa a tutta
la mia visione della storia dell'arte.
Quando ho studiato i Kuros dicevo:
"Ma perché i Kuros sono importanti?"
Bellissimi, come questa statua,
tutti messi così, uguali.
Quando invece, 400 anni dopo c'era già
Laocoonte, l'Ellenismo,
il Galata morente.
Queste cose mi piacevano molto di più.
Sembravano molto di più i Masters,
mi piacevano molto di più,
(Risata)
quindi ero in grado di capirle, no?
Questa cosa è andata sempre peggio.
Quindi mi sono concentrato
su questo tipo di disegno,
mi sono scavato un buco più profondo,
mi sono allontanato sempre di più
da quella cosa che mi spaventava,
da quei disegni che non riuscivo a capire.
Il mio problema umano non si è risolto,
continuavo ad allontanarmi,
però seguivo la mia strada.
Se posso fare una confessione peggiore,
sono arrivato ad un punto in cui,
quando ho cominciato a vedere
i primi i pittori giapponesi,
in questo caso vediamo Hokusai e Utamaro,
per me erano tutti uguali.
Vedevo opere così e dicevo:
"Sembrano fatti dalla stessa persona".
Mentre se penso a Caravaggio e Leonardo,
non mi viene in mente.
Senz'altro c'è molta distanza cronologica.
Però quando ho scoperto l'arte giapponese
non riuscivo a distinguere gli artisti,
mi sembravano tutti uguali.
Sono cresciuto in un momento in cui
c'erano i videogiochi giapponesi,
l'animazione giapponese
e i fumetti giapponesi,
e quando sono usciti non scorderò mai
che la tendenza era quella
di derubricarli
a disegni brutti,
tutti uguali, fatti con lo stampino.
Era un escamotage commerciale,
dicevano, per fare cose a basso costo.
In qualche modo queste due cose si sommano
anche con la visione dei disegni
dei miei compagni delle elementari,
secondo me,
con cui ho litigato molte volte.
Queste liti mi sono rimaste dentro
perché non capivo come era possibile
non vedere la differenza
fra Caravaggio e questa cosa qui.
Sta di fatto che anni, dopo
ho avuto una fortuna enorme
perché un mio caro amico, che si chiama
Gianluca Folì e fa l'illustratore,
mi ha fatto vedere i manuali di disegno
di un pittore eccezionale
che si chiama Hokusai.
Hokusai, che è l'autore
oltre che di uno dei due
disegni che vedete qui,
è anche l'autore delle famose vedute
del monte Fuji, dove si vede anche
la famosa onda tsunami,
insomma quel pittore lì.
Lui ha scritto diversi manuali di disegno,
oltre ad aver catalogato tutte le specie
animali e vegetali esistenti in Giappone,
e questo manuale di disegno si presenta
con una logica molto diversa
da quelli occidentali.
Questi sono due esempi classici
di insegnamento e di studio del disegno,
forse gli occidentali più importanti
che abbiamo avuto nel disegno,
ossia Leonardo e Leon Battista Alberti,
quest'ultimo fu l'inventore
della prospettiva moderna,
e Leonardo con i suoi studi tecnici
di anatomia.
Quello che è formidabile
di questi due disegnatori
è che si sono interrogati sul perché
le cose sono fatte in un certo modo.
Hanno ragionato sul fatto che il disegno
dovrebbe partire da questa logica:
capire come funzionano le cose, per poi
poterle disegnare in maniera consapevole.
Partire dal dentro e andare all'esterno.
Questo è Burne Hogart,
un famosissimo disegnatore.
Oppure di ragionare da forme semplici
e arrivare alla complessità.
Mai partire dalla superficie,
perché significherebbe
non capire cosa si sta facendo.
Questo è invece il manuale
di disegno di Hokusai,
che non parte dalla profondità,
parte dalla superficie.
E già da come è impaginato,
si capisce che siamo davanti al segreto
della differenza tra i disegni
dei miei compagni delle medie
e quelli di Caravaggio.
In particolare si vede
un'area bassa con un disegno
e poi si vede un'area alta,
separata dal resto della pagina,
dove ci sono una serie di caratteri,
di segni, di atomi pittorici,
di oggetti della mente,
che sono numerati da un piccolo simbolo,
accanto ad ogni oggetto,
che è il numero che rappresenta
l'ordine in cui bisogna disegnare
quell'oggetto sotto.
La cosa straordinaria è che questi oggetti
rappresentano la soluzione più pratica
per disegnare quella cosa
in quella specifica situazione.
È il modo migliore per disegnarla
perché è quella accettata da tutti,
è una convenzione.
L'enorme differenza tra Hokusai
e un disegnatore occidentale
è che mentre gli occidentali
cercavano l'unicità nel disegno,
cercavano di cogliere
quell'attimo irripetibile
di quella persona al tramonto,
da quel punto di vista specifico,
di mettere tutta la propria personalità
nel segno.
Hokusai dice invece che il disegno
non sta solo nel segno in sé,
ma nell'ordine in cui si mettono i segni.
Comincia quindi a interpretare i disegni
come se fossero parte di un vocabolario,
come se fossero dei timbri
che vanno lavorati a freddo,
che vanno scalati, ruotati.
La cosa interessante è che insegna
il disegno con la stessa logica
con cui si insegna la scrittura,
con un ordine in cui vanno fatti i segni,
per rappresentare un'idea,
come un albero in questo caso.
E fa di più.
Questo uomo di spalle che vedete,
questo samurai,
è disegnato con questo oggetto,
qui dentro lo leggete questo simbolo, no?
Questo significa montagna
e raffigura il samurai
che guarda la montagna,
quindi, in questo caso,
lui sta usando la montagna
per dire che è dentro al samurai.
Quindi è un salto di linguaggio clamoroso.
Quello che sta dicendo Hokusai
è che mentre noi occidentali
ci siamo dannati a cercare
un neologismo per ogni disegno,
lui ti dice il vocabolario è quello,
le parole sono quelle,
è l'ordine in cui le usi
che fa fare differenza.
Per scrivere Moby Dick non devi
inventarti ogni volta tutte le parole,
scrivi Moby Dick con le parole
che usa anche [Melville].
La cosa che è interessante è che
anche fra Collodi,
Ungaretti e Pascoli,
la differenza non è il dizionario,
ma la scelta delle parole e dell'ordine
in cui vengono posizionate.
Questa non è la convenzione che ha cercato
il designer Otto Neurath con Isotype,
per capirci, i simboli maschio
e femmina nelle porte dei bagni,
dove c'è l'idea di dire:
"Secondo me esiste un modo universale,
che capiscono tutti,
di cos'è un uomo e cos'è una donna".
Qua è semplicemente il modo più comodo,
perché è quello che usano tutti.
Con la fine del sakoku,
l'autosegregazione del Giappone,
che è durata un centinaio di anni,
forse 150, non ricordo,
comunque a metà dell'Ottocento,
il Giappone apre i porti e la sua arte
arriva all'altra parte del mondo.
Succede questo:
qui vedete Takehisa Yumeji
e questo è Koloman Moser.
Si crea una koinè del linguaggio globale,
e tutti i disegnatori cominciano
a contaminarsi.
E l'idea di efficienza che porta
il disegno giapponese
diventa popolarissima in Europa.
Questo è Van Gogh.
Se andate ad Amsterdam trovate
i suoi studi di pittura giapponese.
Lui scrive al fratello:
"I giapponesi hanno un modo
di disegnare molto efficiente.
Non lo capisco, però devo capirlo meglio".
Qui vedete Carl Larsson e Bilibin.
Questo è un disegnatore giapponese
che alla fine del sakoku
lascia il Giappone e comincia a disegnare
cose occidentali con la linea giapponese
e somiglia a Winsor McCay, un disegnatore
che inizia a disegnare in quel momento,
colpito dall'Art Nouveau, movimento
a sua volta influenzato dal Japonisme,
che guardava al Giappone.
50 anni dopo Winsor McCay,
Osamu Tezuka deciderà di utilizzare
la linea chiara per stabilire i canoni
del fumetto giapponese,
fatto con lo stampino,
con dei disegni approssimativi
dal punto di vista occidentale.
Non funziona più, non torna più indietro,
vabbè lo salta,
mi manca una slide.
Lui definisce sostanzialmente,
quello che utilizzeremo poi negli emoji,
stabilisce tutte le espressioni
standard del fumetto giapponese.
Questo è un tipo di linguaggio
che troviamo assolutamente familiare
oggi con i nostri smartphones, no?
Quante volte vi è capitato di dire
ad un vostro amico in chat:
"Caspita, mi fai un sacco ridere"?
Ormai usiamo gli emoji e stiamo imparando
anche noi questo tipo di linguaggio,
sta diventando un linguaggio diffusissimo.
Per farla breve,
ci sono fumettisti
che hanno capito questa cosa
in maniera eccezionale, ad esempio
Maicol & Mirco hanno capito certamente
- come dice anche Poincaré -
che nel disegno approssimativo
si nasconde la perfezione,
perché si stabilisce un codice
di comunicazione
che va oltre il figurativo.
Quando vediamo questo quadrato
possiamo dare per scontato che sia
perfetto, con tutti gli angoli a 90 gradi
e con tutti i lati uguali.
Questo l'ha capito Maicol,
che per disegnare Dio
ha usato un triangolo approssimativo,
un tipo di ragionamento
sicuramente molto vicino
al risultato del percorso
per cui si è dannato l'anima
Picasso, per dimenticare come si disegna.
O nella visione di Dio di Rublëv
e quindi di Giotto.
Per concludere,
è importante disegnare
bene o disegnare male?
È importante che i disegni siano
fatti bene o fatti male?
Che siano stilizzati o realistici?
Secondo me ci rispondono benissimo
due maestri assoluti del fumetto italiano,
che sono Andrea Pazienza e Gipi.
Andrea Pazienza, qui lo vediamo al vertice
massimo della sua proprietà di linguaggio,
con un disegno anatomico
di un cavallo decapitato
che ruzzola con il peso che solo
qualcuno che l'ha abbracciato un cavallo,
può arrivare a rappresentare
in una maniera così perfetta.
Sotto c'è la testa del suo cavaliere
che schizza via,
con la faccia stupita di Paperino.
Allo stesso modo, Gipi, è in grado
di cogliere tutta la realtà fotografica,
riesce ad ascoltare gli occhi
come un asceta,
cogliere quel punto di giallo
in una nuvola grigia,
riesce a rappresentare la realtà
in tutta la sua drammaticità
e inserisce dentro un uomo disegnato
come disegnano i bambini delle medie,
come il mio compagno di classe, no?
Disegna i suoi personaggi con la materia
con cui sono fatte le parole,
esattamente come faceva Hokusai.
Quindi, il disegno che diventa letteratura
con il naso a triangolo.
La vita disegnata male.
Sono andato fuori tempo massimo,
quindi vi saluto. (Risata)
(Applausi)